ما زالت عمليات الانقاذ والاجلاء مستمره
حتى هذه الساعه هناك اكثر من خمسين الف
شخص موجودين في مراكز ايواء في المناطق
اكثر تضررا في جنوب البلاد تحديدا هاتاي
وكرمان مارش وايضا اديان هذه المناطق هي
المناطق الاكثر تضررا وهناك مراكز وايضا
فتحت في المدارس وصلاه الرياضيه وايضا
هناك خيام لكن هناك صعوبات كبيره تواجه
السلطات التركيه حتى هذه الساعه في عمليات
الانقاذ وعمليات الانجاء الاجلاء ان كان
من ناحيه حاله الطقس السيئه جدا والمترديه
هناك عاصفه ثلجيه تشتد هذه اللحظات وربما
تستمر لايام مقبله وهذا يؤثر بشكل كبير
على عمليات الانقاذ وايضا هناك
مخاوف من هزات
تستمر خلال الساعات المقبله وخلال الايام
المقبله نائب الرئيس التركي تحدث عن اكثر
من 300 هزه ارتداديه منذ يوم امس حتى
اليوم تم تسجيلها بعض هذه الهزات سجلت خمس
درجات واربع درجات على مقياس ريختر وهناك
مخاوف من هذه الهزات الارتداديه خصوصا على
المباني المتصدعه والمتضرره نتيجه
الزلزال الذي ضرب المناطق الجنوبيه يوم
امس وهناك دعوات من السلطات التركيه الى
المدنيين بعدم العوده الى المباني
المتضرره وحتى ان كان هذا الضرر قليل في
هذه المباني خوفا من الهزات الارتداديه
وبالتالي انهيار مباني جديده هناك حديث
ايضا اعلنت السلطات عن اكثر من 5000 مبنى
انهار بشكل كامل وهناك ايضا
الالاف عشرات الالاف من فرق الالقاد
الحكوميه تتحدث يتحدثون عن عشرين الف من
الفرق الحكوميه
تقوم بعمليات انقاذ وايضا هناك الالاف من
المتطوعين الشباب
الاتراك الذين توجهوا تحديدا من منطقه
اسطنبول ومناطق اخرى الى المناطق الجنوبيه
عبر المطارات للمساعده في عمليات الانقاذ
عمليا الوضع صعب احمد